don't worry about how I'm doing it or
anybody else everything works by the way
not everything works for you one of the
biggest reasons the world has conflict
is people keep telling people what they
should do like I'm very happy that
meditation works for you it may not work
for someone else all I'm doing up here
and saying hey think about this but I
don't judge anybody when they don't do
what I do or what I hope they do I want
it for them first of all you need to
know yourself this is what works for me
I only want people to use me as a
prophecy you don't have to do it my way
do you my definition of doing it right
my definition of legacy it's my
definition